welcome to USMLE Step 1 revision
playlist here we talk about natural
killer cell this is a high yield topic
from Immunology these videos are short
and informative so watch the full video
natural killer cells are the Lethal
Weapon of immune system they are like
specialized Ops they are cold blood
killer so they are born to kill
there are important features that
distinguish natural killer cells from
other cell types these are component of
innate immune system they have a set of
activator receptor and a set of
inhibitory receptor
activity receptor allows these NK cells
to engage with a certain cell type or a
infective agent let's say bacteria but
inhibitory receptors prevent this kind
of response NK cells are highly loaded
with cytotoxic granule filled up with
perforin and grenzyme just like a
cytotoxic T Cell NK cells are
distinguished by their lineage marker NK
1.1 on their surface NK cell also
Express FC receptors and fast ligand
which are essential for apoptosis since
they have FC receptor they can take part
in the antibody dependent cellular
cytotoxic response
now NK cells generally scans any cell to
engage but this engagement is prevented
by a MHC class 1 and inhibitory receptor
interaction
when the NK cell does not find a Class 1
MHC molecule bound peptide then it
decides to engage with that particular
cell and eventually secretes several
perforins and granzyme to kill and
eliminate that cell
this kind of response is really
important against viruses because virus
tends to down regulate class 1 MHC
levels and thereby class 1 MHC level
molecule plus one MHC molecules go down
and cytodoxic T cells get confused they
think everything is okay and they don't
have a viral peptide displayed on the
class 1 MHC so they disengage but immune
system has that fail safe
mechanism NK cells scans for these class
1 MHC and when they don't find these
class 1 MHC molecule or they've
understood that MHC molecules are down
regulated they decide to engage and
thereby they eliminate cells containing
uh viruses also viruses can be optimized
by antibodies and these antibodies can
be recognized by FC region of the FC
receptor
and thereby these uh attenuated viruses
or bacteria could be uptaken by NK cells
dendritic cells and many other cell
types so they can participate on ADCC
response if you want to learn more about
these cell types you can always click on
the I button but this is a very short
video
NK cells are triggered by several
cytokines such as il2 il-12 interferon
Alpha and beta NK cell therapy is
nowadays very popular against different
type of cancers
if you want more details you can watch
my Facebook page and Instagram there are
many flashcards which would help you in
your preparation you can support our
Channel by via super thanks you can pay
via PayPal or UPI
see you in next video